well you know Thanksgiving is a
wonderful time it's my favorite holiday
it's a time for celebration gratitude
time to gather around the table with
your family enjoy a wonderful meal
reflect on all the things that you're
thankful for unless you are a deranged
leftist Thanksgiving doesn't exist going
to raise our voices high that we are
still
here in which case you will insist that
Thanksgiving is not so simple there are
nuances as you like to say the word is
Nuance Thanksgiving is is deeply
problematic and that's why every year
around this time of year you'll start
seeing articles like this one which was
just published in the nation headline
should America keep celebrating
Thanksgiving now the article presents
two competing perspectives both sides of
the discussion are put forward and you
have to give the nation credit at least
for giving both sides of the
debate good job son uh as as dumb as you
might think the debate is at least they
gave both sides and um uh you know
that's honestly more than I would expect
from this publication so here's the
first argument presented by a guy named
Shan Sherman quote the sanitized version
of Thanksgiving neglects to mention the
violence land theft and subsequent
decimation of indigenous populations
needless to say this causes tremendous
distress to those of us who are still
reeling from the trauma of these events
to our communities thanksgiving's roots
are intertwined with Colonial aggression
one of the first document thanksgivings
came in 1637 after the colonist
celebrated their Massacre of an entire
Pat Village I do not uh I do not think
we need to end Thanksgiving but we do
need to decolonize it that means
centering the indigenous perspective and
challenging the colonial narratives
around the holiday and every other day
on the calendar by reclaiming authentic
histories and practices decolonization
seeks to honor indigenous values
identities and knowledge this approach
is one of constructive Evolution and
colonizing Thanksgiving we acknowledge
this painful past while reimagining our
lives in a more truthful
manner now by the way in case this
wasn't clear um that was the pro-
Thanksgiving side of the debate yeah
right so they have two sides of the
debate that's what the Pro Sound side
sounds like wait are you serious the
Thanksgiving Defender is a guy who
thinks that the European European
settlers were evil genocidal colonizers
so if that's what thinks here's what the
opponent of the holiday has to say you
want to give thanks give thanks to
native nations who granted settlers some
form of legitimacy by entering into
treaties recognizing them to be in our
homelands those treaties recognize that
Americans are now under our spiritual
custody and have rights to pass through
our country as soon as Americans were
able to impose their will on indigenous
Nations the treaties were violated some
indigenous Nations do not have treaties
and legally this means their Nation
should be intact those of us who have
treaties have defensible legal claims to
lands that are now occupied by private
American settlers under us law November
is already Native American Heritage
Month Thanksgiving could be something
better a day to appreciate the truth of
a Native American history and Native
Americans contributions to our lives
let's tell a different story by dropping
the LIE of Thanksgiving and begin a
truth's
giving yes let's tell the truth of
Thanksgiving he says let's tell the
story that no one's ever heard before
and that's why every year around this
time there are dozens of Articles and
videos talking about the alleged truth
that nobody is allegedly talking about
you find this narrative everywhere now
even the website delish.com which is
usually a website where you post recipes
and cooking tips so thick well they have
an article titled the Dark Truth behind
the origins of Thanksgiving the real
story isn't what you learned in school a
few years ago Teen Vogue celebrated the
day by gathering around a group of
sullen surly and Native American girls
to scall at us and tell us quote the
real history behind Thanksgiving watch
Happy Thanksgiving America I'm Don and
I'm here with my friends to tell you the
real history behind this
holiday growing up I knew that what they
told you in school about Thanksgiving
wasn't true that's not the true story
the true story behind Thanksgiving was
after every killing of a whole village
these European settlers celebrated it
and they called it Thanksgiving but it
wasn't until Abraham Lincoln became
president that it became an official
holiday
jeez cheer up ladies this is what you're
celebrating though you think you're
celebrating family togetherness and all
that happy stuff but that's not what
you're celebrating these unhappy Native
American girls they will tell you what
you're celebrating and they say that you
are celebrating murder and
death which I I mean you know how many I
guess they're right like how many how
many times countless times that we've
all been sitting around around the
Thanksgiving table and someone says uh
you know let's go around the table and
talk about what we're thankful for we go
around the table and say what we're
thankful for oh that's not necessary
Clyde I'll start and then uh you know
everybody says well I'm thankful for
murder and death I'm thankful for murder
and
genocide happens all the time right and
that's why Thanksgiving has been
declared uh by some a national day of
morning here's the ABC affil affiliate
in Boston explaining this day of morning
watch raising their voices to be heard
after feeling silenced for centuries why
do we gather today 400 years later we
join to raise our voices high that we
are still here we are not conquered and
we are not defeated as many were
enjoying the Thanksgiving Parade
indigenous people of Massachusetts
protested the holiday that for them is
not one to celebrate Plymouth is Rich
with history but not the truth of the
Indians I don't know if you saw there I
think that was uh the woman's name was
Chief
ladybug and she was dressed as a ladybug
this is apparently what the day of
morning consists of first of all I don't
think it's appropriate to wear to dress
up as a ladybug for the day of morning
this is a day of morning the tonal shift
there doesn't feel right um but you can
you know you could do this you can
choose to sit at the table and eat
delicious food and have a great time
with your family or you can take part in
the day of morning which means listening
to various Native American people
lecture you about alleged atrocities
committed hundreds of years ago do you
want turkey or do you want an
ill-tempered lecture it's a tough choice
here's what the lecture sounded like at
a different day of morning event last
year listen the peat people were burned
alive in the middle of their sleep at
night in
1637 Mass Bay Colony Plymouth Colony
Providence Plantation Mystic Seaport all
English colonies banded together to burn
women and children while they slept in a
village at night they barricaded the
exit they did not allow anyone to leave
they wanted them to burn they were proud
that they burned this country was proud
to write we could smell their burning
Rotting Flesh for over a mile away it's
written folks please read it on your own
I am not making this up I like how he's
trying to convince the crowd listen
folks the white man they're they're evil
I'm telling you they these are people
that came to a national day of mour on
Thanksgiving so I'm pretty sure they're
already on your side I don't think you
need to convince them enough said
they're they're already they wouldn't be
there if they didn't already agree now
he says that uh this country was proud
to write that we could smell their
burning Rotting Flesh from over a mile
away this country wrote that this entire
country which didn't even exist as a
country at that time apparently wrote
that phrase and committed that alleged
atrocity that's why we need to have a
national day of morning instead of a day
of Thanksgiving I've got a holiday gift
idea that's sure to make you the hero of
the season now we all know the holidays
can be a bit hectic the shopping the
cooking the never ending list of things
to do but fear not because I've
discovered a gift that's not just
thoughtful it's downright transformative
the gift of genu cell skincare from now
until Christmas genu cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
my listeners at genucell.com
walshy treat yourself and your loved
ones to the absolute best skin care in
the world those troubling forehead
wrinkles spine lines skin redness yes
even a sagging jawline will disappear
right before your eyes with Gen cell
most popular collection Jus cell
promises immediate effects you'll see
results in less than 12 hours guaranteed
or your money back Jus cell made
Christmas come early this year they sent
out a ton of their products for our crew
to try the crew was so excited to get
their hands on the products and see for
themselves how great the products really
are everyone was extremely impressed the
quality and how different it felt in
comparison to other skincare products
you deserve to look and feel your best
this holiday season go to jal.com Walsh
YT to get this incredible holiday
discount every order today is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping that's
genucell.com
walshy today now let me let me make two
points about all
this first of all it's true that the
traditional story of Thanksgiving that
they used to tell young children in
school decades ago is simplistic and
there's probably a certain element of
Legend to it every country has its
Legends every country has its
foundational
myths uh there is there is nothing
Sinister about that
stories are passed down through the
generations details are lost over time
sometimes details are added um all to
preserve the central theme or message in
the story every culture has its
Legends and really our understanding of
all historical events from centuries ago
is at the very least
incomplete we don't have camera footage
to review so we can uh only go by what
people involved said happened or what
people who talked to people involved
said
happened so none of this is
revelatory we all understand
this okay so every time they they they
say what did you know you know what they
told you in second grade about
Thanksgiving did you know that wasn't
the whole story of course it's not the
whole story you idiot it was in second
grade I I assume it wasn't the whole
story um duh exactly none of that
changes the basic meaning of
Thanksgiving or undermines or debunks
the basic Central story of
Thanksgiving besides the old simplistic
story of the holiday has now been
replaced with a new simplistic story in
the new simplistic version the native
tribes were all a bunch of peaceful tree
hugging hippies in tune with the Earth
and nature singing Kumbaya when they
were viciously slaughtered by the white
man the pilgrims overtook the Native
Americans and took everything that they
had worked so hard for the actual truth
is that the native tribes were in a
const state of War long before any white
man set foot on these Shores violence
was an integral part of so-called
indigenous culture all indigenous
cultures because it was not just one
culture okay these were these were
desparate tribes stretched out all over
the hemisphere and violence was an
integral part of all of them no
exceptions as for their contact with
European settlers sometimes the contact
was peaceful on both sides on some
occasions the settlers committed
atrocities on some occasions the Indians
committed atrocities on some occasions
the atrocities on either side were
basically unprovoked on Plenty of
occasions there was mutual combat
between the two sides the peat people
mentioned in that last video were not
helpless victims they were at war with
the colonists they lost the war they
were conquered such is the way of
History such is the law of Conquest
which the peat like all Indians well
understood they had done plenty of
conquering themselves in fact and this
was a very common occurrence the
colonists had Indian allies in their
fight against the peat and the tribes
allied with the colonists were the ones
that the peat had previously conquered
and slaughtered and so they were a
little bit miffed at the
Pequot of course the Native American
dude up on stage for the day of morning
festivities um or any of the the rest of
them they don't mention any of this they
never do they never acknowledge even one
of the many many many countless
instances of Indian tribes inflicting
horrific Savage violence on innocent
colonists including women and children
and on each other they never acknowledge
it because they don't want you to
realize that this land was not stolen it
was conquered fair and square the
previous conquerors of this land were
then themselves conquered that's the way
it
goes second you know even if it's true
that most of the settlers were peaceful
and that often times um they were the
victims of brutal violence by the
Indians and that there was mutual combat
between the two sides and the Indians
simply lost the battle they lost the war
it it was a war and they
lost sorry but you
lost even if all that's
true does it justify whatever actual
atrocities the settlers committed no of
course it doesn't do I deny that such
atrocities were committed no of course I
don't but here's what I do say about
those cases and I'll put it as gently as
possible
get the hell over it move on just just
yeah move on are you saying we should
just get over and move on atrocities
that were committed hundreds of years
ago yeah basically just like get over it
um the guy in the last video was
complaining about something that
supposedly happened in
1637 that's nearly 400 years ago you
cannot actually be angry about something
that happened 400 years ago
if you are then you are insane you are
an insane person if you're actually mad
about stuff that happened four centuries
ago I feel like I'm taking crazy pills
that is 16 Generations we are as close
to the pilgrims today as the pilgrims
were to the Crusades that's the amount
of time we're dealing with and yet we
have people in this country so young
that 911 is ancient history to them
pretending to be distraught and
devastated by events that occurred 150
years before the Declaration of
Independence was written do you realize
how crazy that
is pretending to be actively traumatized
about stuff that happened centuries ago
is psychotic what are you then I ask you
what mentally ill imagine if you found
me in the corner sobbing and you asked
me what was wrong and I said I'm just
really upset about the burning of the
Library of Alexandria in 48 BC by the
way I've got news for you 400 years ago
almost everybody's life was brutal and
tragic if we're supposed to be sad about
Misfortune suffered by people we never
met way back in the distant past then we
will never stop being sad almost
everyone everywhere suffered greatly
back in those days there are plenty of
people still suffering greatly today if
you want to empathize with people's pain
maybe choose people who are currently
living not people who had decomposed in
the ground 400 years ago not people who
died 300 years before the automobile was
invented now in final analysis history
contains an essentially infinite amount
of suffering and atrocities and outrages
and injustices it also contains heroism
and sacrifice and courage and
achievement it is up to us to decide
which of those things in our National
History we will focus on I contend that
the healthiest category to focus on the
thing that you focus on if you want to
be a thriving and happy and healthy
Society is the latter which isn't to say
that we outright deny and never discuss
the former of course we acknowledge that
bad things were done in our history we
shouldn't try to erase that from the
history books and nobody is but
ultimately you will look back on your
history with pride and gratitude or with
resentment and despair you will focus on
the Triumph or the
tragedy the people of all other nations
across the world or at least the
non-western world they choose to focus
on the Triumph of their ancestors which
breeds national pride and patriotism and
gratitude in the modern West we are the
only ones who have decided to basically
ignore all of the positive and
concentrate almost exclusively on the
bad so much so that even our day of
Thanksgiving has become at least in some
Corners times of
mourning and what has that strategy
gotten us it's only made us resentful
Sullen depressed
ungrateful it has made us worse people
and our country a worse
country that's why I will not partake in
this historical self-
flatulation instead I celebrate the
incredible Valor and intrepidness of my
ancestors I take pride in this country's
history and those who made it possible
for this country to exist in the first
place I am happy that they came here and
that they
conquered I am thankful for their
Conquest I will give thanks for it on
Thanksgiving
and for so much
else and for everybody else I will say
they are today
cancel